let's talk about the news let's talk
about the absolute chaos that is
affecting this country and man the spark
of civil war never seemed closer we got
this from the bbc now i i chose the bbc
on purpose because it's not an american
news outlet so i was really interested
in how they would frame it especially
consider kind of left establishment
they write steve bannon congress plots
criminal charge for former trump aide
mr bannon has been summoned to testify
before the congressional panel
investigating the riot on thursday he
did not appear prompting the head of the
committee to schedule a tuesday vote to
hold him in critical criminal contempt
if
convicted mr bannon faces a fine up to
one year in prison democrats say he is
trying to delay the probe mr bannon a
former right-wing media executive who
became mr trump's chief strategist was
fired from the white house yeah yeah we
get it he was asked to testify regarding
his communication with mr trump a week
before the incident as well as his
involvement in discussing plans to
overturn the election results that saw
joe budden in the white house
i don't i don't know if that's fair
framing he's ought to overturn the
election results he certainly thinks
there's widespread fraud but what
they're doing is there was this thing he
said where he was like you know i was
there and i was talking with trump right
before the rally and like helped
organize it or something and they're
trying to take that and reframe it as
though he said he organized the riot
which he didn't now my bigger my the the
bigger thing here to me
that's scary
establishment democrats and for all
intents and purposes republicans but
they're actually democrats
are now actually going after people
they're going after private citizens to
force them to testify in their in their
crackpot probe this if they actually
come and arrest abandon over this it's
it's like we're dangerously close in my
opinion to a spark of some kind of civil
war
um i i wouldn't be quite so pessimistic
in the short term because i think
ultimately the the amount of time it
will take them to even get to the point
right like
congress doesn't have the ability to
charge somebody with contempt or
prosecutor right they're they're relying
on referring it to the us attorney of dc
and then that actually has to go through
a normal criminal process
um bannon's not just making a claim that
basically he's not he's making a claim
like i read the lawyer the letter he
sent to his lawyer or his lawyer sent to
the congress
and it he's they're claiming look the
you know the president's claimed his
executive privilege
and
i'm as an aide to him or somebody who
you know was talking to them i'm bound
by that i'll be happily to produce the
documents if you come to an agreement
with the trump you know the trump people
or if you get a court order
saying so
um under those circumstances i don't
know if they're gonna be able to prove
criminal contempt it'll take a long time
to get proven
but i think
the really big problem here is you know
you notice what they're talking about
what is the january 6 commission about
is it designed to help with any
legislative purpose no no it's
that and that's the bigger issue right
yeah i'm not saying that we're at the
point where you know all of a sudden
we're going to see another you know cnn
showing up at six in the morning to
bannon's house or anything like that but
we're we're moving from we had in the
trump era lock her up you know arrest
hillary clinton and a lot of people
being like yeah she should be arrested i
mean she should be locked up for the
email scandal at the very least let
alone
lots of other things that went down with
with uh you know the clinton foundation
and serious things that should be
investigated
and now we're moving towards
people are actively cheering and
screaming on both sides for the arrest
of the other side i can't imagine
regardless of who's right or wrong this
is going to lead to somewhere
good no it's not and the fact that we're
even doing committees like this like
again congress is the reason they have
subpoena power they're not they're not a
court they're not and they also don't
have law enforcement power right that's
in the executive branch they have
legislative power so the goal of any
committee has to have some legislative
purpose they can you know it makes sense
they can subpoena something the
executive branch is doing because they
kind of oversee it they authorize the
funding for it but here it's like
they're doing an investigation
of private criminal behavior
right or what they think pri
objectionable private behavior well
that's that's a star chamber
like there they don't have to go get a
warrant when they go issue these
subpoenas
um and so there has to be some
limitation on what they can subpoena
based on and they're and apparently
they've just decided no we we can just
subpoena people to embarrass our
political opponents yeah and that's
efficient but this this is not nothing
new i mean they've been doing it to
lower level people and i think it's only
escalating to where it's now and i
wouldn't be surprised if even if it does
take a long time that they're still
going to try to go after bannon
criminally because they go after people
politically all the time you look at the
activities of the fbi they are extremely
political they choose and select who
they go after oh jeffrey epstein 30
years doesn't matter oh someone lied to
congress
we have to get a swat team in front of
their house with cnn right in the
morning uh as fast as we can as long as
the name's not james clapper exactly
exactly or dr fauci uh our lord and
savior dr fauci who's who's always right
never wrong and that was really one of
my favorite moments
when rand paul was like
you conducted gain of function research
gain of function research is defined as
modifying a virus to increase in you
know infectivity and then vouchers like
we didn't do gain of function research
we just modified a virus for increased
infectivity he went full lawyer yeah
right he went he went full like i am
being deposed you know fauci who's
normally like open in his language and
very it is not
yeah it is a large wooden object with a
latch that when you turn a metal object
releases it allowing that that that
wooden plank to be moved yeah and it's
just different just a coincidence that
it's almost the same genetic sequence
that we were asking for grant funding
with the exact cleavage site with the
exact sickness that's going around the
world right now it's just you know a
coincidence uh not here to question
anything uh you know youtube overlords
we love fiouchi you see that woman who
was skydiving
yes
there's a woman and she's skydiving and
the instructor who they're flying in
tandem his helmet said arrest fouchy
infowars.com
and then she posted like i trusted this
man with my life and it wasn't until
after we saw the photo we realized what
the sticker said and she was like
shocked and i'm like what did you think
was going to happen that like this
flight instructor was like i'm going
down with her to like get her or
something they're attached together
they've got a sticker on us for it
that's how insane it is though you know
i think
there there's a one of the phenomena one
of the
circumstances in the culture war
conservatives don't care interacting
with the left or i shouldn't even say
conservatives but like whatever the
freedom side is
doesn't mind going to a store owned by a
bunch of people with biden flags
there's a biden flags all over and they
sell cupcakes i look i want a cupcake i
don't care that much the other way
around though the throw brick through
your window this woman's freaking out
like i can't even go skydiving so
look donald trump didn't do
nearly enough with the presidential
powers the democrats as soon as they get
power
there it's the equivalent of throwing a
brick through the window of the right
yeah there's a lot of republicans i
remember remember the national emergency
debate about whether the president
should declare a national emergency to
try and build the wall
and how much like established
republicans were like well this will set
a really bad precedent that democrats
could exploit and it's like you say that
and then when democrats take power they
all complain about look at all the
unprecedented things that democrats are
doing it's like if they do unprecedented
things maybe you shouldn't really care
that much about what precedence you set
because they don't the democrats don't
care but well they're they're paid you
know a lot of money just to be you know
the second level democrats you didn't
know about this they're they're paid
just to be the cushion for you know the
globalist agenda
that is such a good analogy who came up
with that one it wasn't me originally uh
but it might have been it might have
been kirk schlichter i don't know but
the republicans the washington generals
to the democrats harlem globe some have
been yarvin uh back in the day i don't
know but like that's that's actually i
think yeah it's a very good description
like what is their purpose and so people
are like how come tim pool is always
ragging on democrats i'm like because
mitch mcconnell is sitting on his hands
that's about it yeah i mean like there's
not much to complain about other than
he's ineffective and well i'll tell you
this how much money did he make over his
career in the senate he's tens of
millions of dollars man screw all of
these corrupt
yeah i was almost going to swear but i
won't do it it's all the same it's all
the same they make say they somehow they
get a salary of you know 170 to 200k
they become worth 30 40 million dollars
nancy pelosi maxine waters buying a
mansion it's all the same there's
there's people on tick tock literally
making their careers off of stock picks
that nancy pelosi makes uh the level of
of seriously this is not funny this is
real
the amount of
the amount of money that she made is
absolutely insane but but what's
happening to bannon i believe is a part
of a slippery slope because we saw what
happened politically when people on the
left when they were protesting for left
issues were arrested they raised money
for them they got them out they hired
pros they they elected prosecutors
george soros dumped a huge amount of
money into local politics and they were
able to rig the game where their people
don't go to jail their people don't get
prosecuted but if you sneeze in the
wrong direction if you're a part of the
opposite party you're going to see a
heavy hammer come down on you
and with on average americans committing
three felonies a day when we have the
politization of our justice system we're
slowly evolving into the destruction of
it and i think this is the start
i think it started a long time ago but i
think this is the beginning of it and
it's i think it's only going to swell
and be made worse moving forward i see
someone in the chat said tim run for
senate and you know i was thinking about
it just now and i'm like if i did and i
won
i would get really really rich you know
because you you as a member of the
senate you'll make on average i think
two to three million dollars a year on
your 174 thousand dollar salary so it
sounds sounds pretty good you know run
for senate somehow become a millionaire
because it's just magic it's just you
know just all of a sudden money just
appears and yeah no one knows where it
comes from well i mean you know it comes
from hunter biden style deals you just
you just need to have children and then
you can have them go earn
you could get a you could probably get a
cushy job at pfizer afterwards or or
google or you know you'll get some
donations from a lot of these
multinational corporations and
industrial complexes i mean your life is
set and you get a congressional salary
for the rest of your life do you really
though i heard that was a myth i don't
i've heard that was true someone will
fact-check us very soon here in the
comment section which i'm paying
attention to i don't know but uh
i just
getting back to this i i want democrat
republicans next time in their power
which they probably will be and you know
we might have a desantis or somebody as
like a president yeah but like look
unless republicans win primaries
and that means getting america first or
populist candidates to actually win
you're gonna end up with kevin mccarthy
mcconnell graham and they're gonna be
like i'm gonna fight extra hard and then
the camera turns off and they high five
joe biden
the congress i don't know how to fix the
congress problem but i think you know
the executive branch is fixable in a
world where
a republican executive branch was
particularly ruthless in a way that made
democrats realize maybe we need to
change the rules but trump you mean not
trump trump trump is not the answer on
that front i mean
people trump was
not ruthless enough well i mean he was
just like a novice pilot in a 747
cockpit like he didn't he got he didn't
know what buttons to press and like
early on he pressed some buttons really
aggressively with like the travel ban
and a few other things like that and got
zapped and so then he just kind of was
like i'm just gonna put the thing on
autopilot like i'm when it comes to
exercising his executive authority to
try and like screw the other side he's
just like no i'm not doing that and it's
like he could have pardoned a lot of
people he could have done so much with
his power and it's like that's why one
of the reasons i'm like i want a lawyer
next time because this isn't you know
people are like man we need a deal maker
it's like no no we're not making deals
anymore there's no deals to be made this
isn't bipartisan world this is use the
legal authority that you have available
to you to to cement your power and make
the other side's lives miserable isn't
desantis a lawyer yes okay that's our
harvard law degree thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments and
super chat and we actually will read
your comments on the show don't forget
to like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you